i am very excited to introduce you to
our next guest she is an extraordinary
teacher
that we recently
met up with in chicago take a look
i feel like it's very important for
teachers to be active in their
communities so that they can understand
first hand how to make it a better place
my name is amy castaneda i've been
teaching for 24 years i teach
kindergarten through second grade art at
ortizday dominguez in the little village
neighborhood in chicago i moved into
little village because i knew wherever i
was going to teach i'd also want to live
there i just feel like it's very
important to be able to know the
families that i'm teaching and
understand the same things that they're
experiencing
one of the things in our neighborhood is
a lot of safety issues and parents feel
uncomfortable letting their kids play
outside so when we first moved in there
was some violence that was directed
specifically at us we had issues with a
gang that set our house on fire and was
trying to intimidate us because they
felt like we were intruding
as a result of that violence my husband
and i started a nonprofit it's called
beyond the ball and it's sports-based
youth development and basically what
we're trying to do is make the community
a safer place for kids to play
i have a lot of long-term relationships
with my students is i've been in the
neighborhood for 24 years i just this
summer went to a wedding i go to
baptisms i go to quinceaneras my
favorite part about being a teacher is
the energy that kids have when they look
at art it's just amazing to see
what they see through their eyes and i
might have taught it a hundred times and
it's for them this is the first time and
they get really excited about hey blue
and yellow make green and they bring it
to me and they're like look what i did
it made green
that that just thrills them
my hopes for the school are that kids
get more materials that help them become
who they are going to be what would be
really influential is to have more items
that are concentrating on steam like the
science technology engineering arts and
mathematics a lot of different
activities helps them understand what
they really enjoy and what they really
are going to be good at
what inspired me to be a teacher is my
mom and dad
my dad was a coach for many years of
little league baseball and my mom was
always like a community organizer and i
feel like i get that from my parents of
wanting to make my neighborhood a better
place and i feel like teachers are one
of those main components in
neighborhoods that can bring more
resources to a community and can really
advocate for kids
[Music]
oh i'm so happy to meet you i'm so happy
to meet you i can't believe this this is
like they said a surprise but i'm like
what
i'm shocked i feel like i have so much
to learn from you and so many questions
i want to ask good i need to learn from
amy and we're at school so that's sort
of perfect yes and you're a teacher yes
could i be your student
all right let's go inside and keep
talking to you so i have so much to
learn
come on in amy
[Applause]
amy if you want to come stand over here
and um jesus thank you so much for
showing up today if you would love to
say anything to amy my name's jesus
martinez and i met amy when i was in
third grade she was there my wedding day
aiming because of you
being so kind
empathetic with everyone
i learned that from you and that's why i
try to be
thank you for making
you know the person i am today
thank you so much thank you
i would also love to call up to the
microphone jasmine
hi i'm jasmine vega
i've had the honor and the pleasure of
knowing miss amy for about nine years
now
she is just incredibly selfless
she's helped me
get through the loss of my brother
she's prayed for me when i couldn't and
just been a
lending ear a shoulder to cry at and
just helped me
get through that thank you i am so sorry
for your loss and i'm very appreciative
that you had someone that you could lean
on
in such a difficult time i'm so in awe
of your guys's
network here
and we just want to encourage you
to keep doing what you're doing so if
you guys don't mind separating
we have over twenty thousand dollars
worth of stem-related educational toys
and supplies from local chicago
companies learning resources and hand to
mind thank you so much this is awesome
thank you very much
wonderful oh my goodness i also want to
mention conagra brands stepped up to the
plate and they're gonna give ten
thousand dollars which is this check
right oh my goodness
[Applause]
oh my goodness
thank you so much
i i'm super surprised i'm like
i love him
amy i want to ask my most burning
question when you're going through
adversity
when things are not easy when you don't
have enough resources when you are
dealing with gang violence
when you are trying to keep your schools
safe what do you tell yourself so that
maybe
somebody watching the show or myself or
anyone in this room can have a take away
of something they could say to
themselves to be strong keep going and
take care of people i get excited when i
see a child and they're at our programs
and they're playing safely and they're
part of our community and that just
gives me hope and then also i have a
husband who's very motivating to me and
he come here
it does take a village work and
friendship and partnership that being
said we are all here to to specifically
say thank you to you amy and to
encourage you to keep doing what you're
doing
[Music]
you